ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Motion Picture Association of
America mr. Jack Valenti previously an
honorary award bestowed upon individual
by the Board of Governors of this
Academy has always been in recognition
of someone's contribution to the art of
filmmaking whether it be in the creative
or the productive sense but tonight the
Academy presents an award to someone who
is not a maker of film but it's truly a
savior of them films saved from
destruction ordered destroyed by
producers who didn't like the way they
turned out or by political groups whose
tyranny felt threatened by their
existence films in the process of decay
by simple neglect but this man stood
guard when no one else was there because
he was committed to the belief that art
cannot be explained it is felt and
therefore it's necessary to the quality
of life today as the director of the
cinémathèque française in Paris he has
dedicated his life to see that all films
live forever and so tonight we are proud
to present this award to the curator to
the collector to the conscience of the
cinema honoree lengua
is mr. Gene Kelly
and it's a lot of our duty present a mr.
Oscar
business and says business on this set
tusky counting on us because so host
yogi left
Stravinsky I deliver new food use in
America a sea bass gives it a food you
seen in American cinema francais ICT the
dalek dance
Hanwha before God our exist city say to
the to well around 1916 and 1917 in
France
everyone who counted or I should better
say all the really important artists in
France like Picasso and Proust and
Diaghilev and Stravinsky became crazy
about the American cinema they fell in
love with it to such an extent that they
uplifted the create [ __ ] and the
makers of French films from de nuke
Renoir and other girls way back then up
to nowadays Truffaut and Godard and this
is a reason I liked so much the film
America
to present the award for best sound is a
young lady who is attractively outspoken
and a gentleman who is never at a loss
for words he just doesn't have any use
for them here's the talented Candice
Bergen and the star of the paramount
film entitled shanks Marcel muscle
you